oh can I look up the cast before no no
what do you mean no no no no but when
you don't let me do that stop stop now
don't even read okay tell me when you're
ready
[Music]
first of an intro because it's our final
one it's Final Destination five we love
this franchise we heard this one's gonna
be great Final Countdown that's my
prediction for what song's gonna be in
this you got one Greg I'm gonna wait to
see what it looks like the disaster
depth is gonna be and then I will call
the first thing that comes to mind okay
I take back what I said I'm gonna do
that too I want to really quick thank
all you guys of course for being here
this has been one of the most fun
franchises to cover been loving it and
Craig Perry who's been in our comment
boxes showing us love and I appreciate
also the encouragement to let us uh be
openly critical about some stuff we
don't feel like we need to mince our
words whatsoever yeah he's kind of
agreed with us I know but overall I love
the franchise and I already can't wait
for part six even though we haven't seen
part five yet leave a like subscribe all
that good stuff ooh I'm loving the dance
moves on this right now also be a patron
why don't you
you should
already we have full length Reaction
watch logs where you sink up with your
own copy and that's how you can be a
super sexy reject I remembered every
word of it Greg yeah you didn't read it
at all didn't even look like it no Greg
and John cover several shows over there
exclusively with reaction highlights and
watch alongs included let's do it
thank you
okay guessing who's in it just thinking
of names right now Adam Brian
Christopher
Daniel did they
eliminate the 3D I totally hear you Roxy
over
[Music]
oh hell yeah
oh no no they're giving you the castle
okay
remembering it Nicholas I don't know who
you are but I will Emma Bell Emma Bell
Emma Bell that sounds familiar Miles
Fisher who that name sounds actually
familiar that's gonna bother me I know
that name could be miles tellers long
lost Courtney B Vance he's huge Courtney
B Vance let's go Courtney B Vance Arlene
Esco escarpeta good have you seen the
pronunciation people versus OJ David oh
yeah David kochner oh I know him he's a
comedian yeah I know him he's funny he's
a funny guy and Tony are there clues in
this intro we're missing so we saw
skulls we saw shattered glass we saw
what looked like a hot dog
but I don't think was this is a dynamite
is that a hot dog I'm gonna guess the
song We Didn't Start the Fire
oh that's a really good guess no no I'm
gonna go with the Doors Light My Fire oh
that's a really good guess too all I can
think of is Bruce I'm on fire or Bruce
Fire but I don't think this movie's
gonna use a Bruce Springsteen song just
not correct Perry or dude let's go Craig
get it Craig this is when prepper has
the most fun editing
okay barbecue
picnic yeah a breakfast picnic waffle
are they on set isn't this amazing
thanks man just uh remember that when
you see my sales report for last month
I saw it last night
it's okay I'm trying to make a decision
Miles Fisher is that him yeah I
recognize him from what he looks like
Christian Bale and he's played Christian
Bale a lot on YouTube videos
your tickets canceled I was going to
tell you after this weekend
uh tell me what I don't know that I
don't
think it's such a good idea
what the trip what why not
Heartbreaker it's not working out soon I
hate to hear it at least you didn't
ghost the ghost didn't even exist then
but that 12 30 curfew tonight you should
plan on breaking that why
for the naked team building
naked team building baby get it that's
where you see some boobies that's what
we do with all our interns here at real
Rejects
I love that name
that was cute we got a gig on uh Sunday
yeah I'll be there
I already think this movie is better it
just paced better
I'm knowing the characters do you
actually get paid for this internship or
does daddy just increase your allowance
if you want to get rid of that baby fat
you should try the gym yes that baby fat
yeah I know she's disgusting
they're called I love this movie
things that are keeping me interested
you know how many things two things two
predominant things the glasses yeah
we're doing like a really really good
listener by a lot of ladies wait don't
say anything tell me it's the camera
from last Tuesday
when people say shh to me I want a punch
in the face
I'm joking I'm sorry
there he is yeah Whammy I want to be on
the road in 90 seconds
uh well I just saw his car so I'll go
track him down way to show some
initiative Stan
it's gonna be a good day you know what
this intro is doing a really good job at
doing is is settling you into this genre
not the horror part of it like it's it's
just being yeah that's the world that it
is right now before the horror happens I
think that's really good the other ones
are just like we're already in a horror
movie what would you call the genre I
don't know just some like comedy
comedy yeah what are they gonna offer
you that permanent gig at the restaurant
they already did they want to send me to
the flagship restaurant in Paris for who
knows how long could be six months could
be a year in Paris is this a prequel
that's enough from Paris no the first
one was pretty cool I'm with you that's
a good prediction there's got to be some
big twist in this or through line
connective tissue
here we go hey Sam bus crash is that
what we're gonna get what are those for
just something I do to relax me
and for luck luck
get out of the bathroom sir Ball's the
New Black okay so his initial seat is up
there but now his seat's back here is
that what threw it off you feel like
it's usually a choice from the main
character that throws no I know but
remember the plane from the first one we
know where your c ends up is where you
die and that's we got logs again
are we gonna get like some amalgamation
of all the other ones Maybe
[Music]
hey Greg gloomy day
I think the cinematography is so much
better also when is this because it just
seems like it's way more modern
oh snap
clever really give the audience a sense
of how far that fall
[Music]
Dust in the Wind I didn't predict we did
not call that we did not call it
maybe Sail On
nothing was the was the chance we had to
predict something sail away from me
honey
or float on oh interesting so this is
going to be more of a weather effect
we're in the elements the elements man
all right okay budget all right this was
good
Molly come on
[Music]
I know that you don't want to be with me
but I will save you great shot yeah oh
where why is she going that way that was
not a smart bad intern
there's a crush
a three day that was was it 3D I can't
tell no pulp 3D
holy moly are there people on the bus
still I think they're just not one guy
oh oh that a great shot
damn that's a hell of a shot right there
that was cool
are your boobs okay
is okay
wow there's like a real Disaster Movie
[Music]
the bridge is so thin we can do this you
can do what why are you guys going that
way I'm so they gotta cross it oh
good I can't go the other way if you
pencil down can you survive that fall no
I don't think so I think it's like
cement when you hit
good for you Molly
oh
wow do you feel it
but maybe those would help her float
Olivia
[Music]
Molly grab her
oh like a slide
[Music]
maybe she's arrived
yeah we let her float yeah that's
helping her float no no don't get hit by
the car
oh
[Music]
awesome okay but what that taught us is
that if you go down you can survive oh
this is an interesting concept because
maybe she's the only one in his vision
who doesn't die yeah and therefore she's
safe for the movie
foreign
oh no how unfortunate
Hot Tar
s
oh way to go Tom Cruise
damn good jump the effects are amazing
so maybe their lives aren't at risk
maybe they all three made it no matter
what
yeah what a shot this is a really good
effects
who knew climb it like a ladder
oh the eye I think this was in 3D
like a paint can
oh [__]
okay so he's the main guy first yeah we
knew
[Music]
I predicted this would come on again
we all got to get off the bridge is
gonna collapse
what we're all gonna die what the hell
is going on we're all gonna die if we
don't get off this bridge now what if
what if things which eventually happens
that'd be crazy would you listen yes or
no no I wouldn't somebody who's that you
knew said we're all gonna die if you
don't get off this bridge you wouldn't
get off no I would think that they're
just having an anxiety attack about
something
Peter please just follow up Peter Peter
pumpkin eater
what the hell is going on out here
do you still think that is gonna be okay
no
I don't know I've just gotta wait for
some like other twist yeah
[Music]
come on
why would you stop running because
they're on Solid Ground now or something
you know they're not where the bridge is
so they just want to watch why wouldn't
you get your cell phone and record this
[Music]
and they all survived not all of them
everyone on the bus survived every
single person got off yeah I saw it
collapse I knew it would happen I
had a vision psychic phenomena you don't
know how
I'm out of nowhere did Sam have issues
with authority did he ever is hearkening
back more to part one this inner cutting
in the interrogation room and people
thinking it's his fault you see him talk
to anyone that morning on a cell phone
Payphone
just his girlfriend but that was in
person thanks good guy Miss Molly tell
me about the breakup
I think we're doing the song choice
that's personal
I'm chucking up the high winds and
structural damage from remote
construction I wins yeah I'm sending
everyone home high winds have high winds
ever caused that much of a structural
damage on a freeway before I mean maybe
if there is a tsunami or something like
yeah a tornado
employees of pre-sage paper on their way
to a business retreat the other 17
employees were killed in the collapse
bad on the bus or there was another bus
what the our main characters survived
yeah I knew that but you said everyone I
didn't I forgot about the other guys
presage baby
pre-saged paper maybe this is in the
same universe as the office Thunder
Mifflin yeah you heard the news
it's natural causes yeah more like
Supernatural
we cannot have more than one black
person in these movies it's the
surviving teens
hey we got a black cop and now we got
two black people we should all just put
it behind us and be grateful we're still
alive
man the eyebrows on him I was seeing
that eyebrows and dimples
killer that's handsome mom maybe you
work next to them
maybe you work for them
but we all worked with them
huh
this one's feeling like a very refined
version of the other ones but it's still
going through the same beats so I'm
waiting to see like you know what I mean
yeah not feeling like a major drama
Tony Todd
doesn't like to be cheated tell them
early you all just be careful now
okay thanks for the advice
no there's got to be something more to
him I I feel like he is still kind of
Supernatural yeah he's some entity of
sorting he can't just be some guy
well what's the matter with it he said
it was flat no flavor do they want
something else yeah the check I would
hate to work in a restaurant
oh he's looking out for him
yeah but also don't eat something that
the customer has eaten you've never done
that before have you
no you have I don't know I mean
sometimes you're just a plate of fries
in your eyes Boombox outside that's not
how improv works you don't just go no
all I can say is that my life is pretty
plain
did she die in the first Vision I know
he died but did she make it she did make
it yeah or at least he didn't see or die
man they really took note of the last
one of being like super [__] like
fast and they really taken their time
with this one
listen they're letting that gloomy Vibe
like wash over this whole movie getting
you to safety you are the only thing I
care about Molly
she cheated on him Paris we talked about
that I'm not going to root my life for
that job but it's the only thing you've
ever dreamed of huh life is too short
Sam you you have to go after what you
love you can't make somebody else's
choices for the molly
I do like her now though Rachel stayed
behind I have her dreams to be in love
and I rooted for it we all did without
realizing that Rachel gave up her dreams
I don't know I'm just not ready I don't
feel ready oh my God she's about to die
I think you got this really yeah
I mean you love it out there oh she's
gonna fall and break her neck or
something yeah something disgusting is
gonna happen gymnastic injuries are
gnarly I do think this one so far is
doing the best at letting The Grieving
element actually wash over all the
characters
there we go
could be a red herring they've got to
make it cooler or we're going to pass
out
they're working on it you're going to
regret asking for that lady
why does he seem like a villain
come on Candace
got this
chalk your hands actually being
supportive to each other I thought they
were just like a sexual fling and then
they're actually like dating dating oh
no it broke it's bad luck
what's up
Sizzle Sizzle Scorch Scorch now I pass
the torch the ballots are in and one
girl had to win
oh good frame
[Music]
so this actress must actually be a
gymnast or a dancer because she
looked legit
oh no oh no that would be so painful oh
I hate it I hate it I hate it
I've stepped on a nail before and it is
not a pleasant feeling
it's a little screw right
oh and I want to mess you on the sound
design
no no no no no no no no no it's good
be good
oh no
nicely done
done
geez I'm super glad she didn't step on
that have you ever stepped on a nail
it's really painful no I don't think so
Candice
stay loose
that's funny screw loose oh no she's
gonna hurt herself on the thing
the way they shoot that makes it look
like yeah it's really cleverly done
looking good Candace somebody she's
gonna scream that's what's gonna happen
she's gonna scream and then it's gonna
throw her off other girl's gonna step on
the nail he's gonna thrown off oh that's
sick
[Music]
whoa love the disorienting shot there
what is that somehow these screws are
going to come together dude no what no
no no no no no no no no
okay
wow wow
oh that was gnarly oh my God holy [__]
that was [__] insane call 9-1-1
Candice Hershey's a pretzel yo that was
that was great I knew it was gonna be
this other girl threw her off in the
that was great the way they ex that's so
much tension and the build to that and
then the way it all like actually
collapsed that was really well done
let's see if they do what you wanted
which is have the boyfriend actually
mourn she was doing great she was almost
finished with the routine and then
why why did it happen
why does life happen
it's okay Peter it's okay that you're a
pumpkin eater
[Music]
oh Tony Todd is back okay so yeah maybe
he's just some like Angel of Death thing
yeah I feel like you've got something
with Paris yeah that's a bummer about
Candace I guess we all should have seen
that coming gotta dig at what you see
the crazy [__] those gymnasts do I'm
surprised it doesn't happen more often
she's so insensitive Candace was mean to
her though remember she told her to lose
the baby weight oh yeah yeah so it's
warranted what she said
yep same level
it's funny because he works he's in the
office too
that is funny Greg oh isn't that funny
Debbie Downer
so naughty
[Music]
what is he playing his pockets I don't
know I have no idea what he's doing he's
creepy he's gonna get himself killed is
he just randomly stealing [__] yeah I
guess I'll attacks
oh he was the second one to die right I
think so
you shouldn't have buddy I actually
don't know the order of I just know the
last three were eyebrows who wants one
where'd you get these I stole it I got
something better
uh oh
our manga though seems to have adjusted
the fact that we had a pretty crazy
premonition
you know what I'm surprised the main guy
is not like stuck on the fact that he
had a big combination yet
how's he gonna die in a spa romantic
dinner you know somewhere maybe outside
the city hold up I gotta go he's so
creepy I know if he was really good
looking it wouldn't be as creepy you
know what I found out Roxy's never had a
massage before that's true that's insane
yeah kind of freaked out by it ironic
the family operation this
professional experience and uh
exactly what you need I hope she rips
his dick off yeah you have a lovely
little Cantor
yum yum dim sum
see
she's gonna put another dude big dude
why is this guy such a dick yeah he's
the worst you're going the wrong way
there little lady well foreign
okay I'm sorry do you come with
subtitles
gosh
he's doing like Chiropractic stuff whoa
ow you're a little aggressive there
don't you think
okay you're a little aggressive
[Music]
it's not how massages usually go but I
don't know but I don't want you to be
scared this is why I don't want a
massage I want to drink with my
co-workers massages are great
they're necessary
[Music]
oh the shattered glass like the opening
it says scariest roller coaster on it I
did see that that's a reference to the
roller coasters yeah of love she dies
doing something that she's done almost
every day for the last 15 years of her
life she said she didn't want to do it
and I should have stopped her no you're
being supportive honey oh sad boy there
wasn't anything you could have done how
do you know
okay helpful I'm sorry I'm sorry oh
becoming a villain not hot doesn't he
seem like it seems like a young Tom
Cruise Peter just freaked out about
something I don't know what does that
mean anything you
for a movie that's so serious sometimes
the comedy seems kind of very out of
place I could try it a hundred times and
never recreate exactly what happened
here
[Music]
I think it's just die
oh yeah awesome
and acupuncture is that what that is I
think so I've never done acupuncture I
thought they were thinner than that you
know I do like how smart the cop is I
was not just writing it off like he
feels like there's actually Something
Happening Here you understood that you
speak English
two billion people can't be wrong
wow two billion people can't be Wong oh
the joke is that I get it get you wrong
I thought I said two banging people
oh wait wait wait it's great so the
table's gonna break and those are gonna
all go super far inside him food
acupuncture is great for you
it's not very nice you know I constantly
have shoulder and back pain Craig
ah don't move it's gonna go in his eye
or something I just can't you're like
reminds me of the dentist scene
you look so comfortable
30 minutes
table breaks and then he's uh it's just
Greg just stop it just stop the movie
yeah it was so uncomfortable I know
what's gonna happen what's gonna happen
table's gonna break and then he's gonna
fall and those are all gonna go into him
and he's gonna die bro
that's a lot of candles for one massager
yeah probably something with fire too my
dude
uh
oh
hey fire get up it's usually not as bad
as you imagined it to be actually
sometimes it's way worse why isn't he
getting up I think he's like slightly
parallel oh there it is do it do it knew
it knew it knew it knew it knew it Greg
knew it knew it I knew it I knew it I
knew it he's gonna light on fire bro I
mean you should still be alive yeah
ew that is gross
no I don't want to see his face don't
show me his face
dude get out of the room out of the room
get out of the room I thought that the
acupuncture meters were so much thinner
than that yeah but for cinematic
purposes they need to be disturbing
no oh his phone I guess he's gonna go
back for his phone shut the front door
what a dumbass
yeah it's like a ride there
oh
my God
it wasn't so bad I asked you to stop I'm
sorry
Tony Todd see at this point I would be
like going right up to Tony Todd and be
like what the hell is going on why are
you following us what are you doing
ask more questions yeah lucky few
survive a disaster and then one five one
death comes for the wall um
would Doom to die you're supposed to die
on that bridge you're not supposed to be
here he actually sounds sympathetic to
death have somebody else in your place
and then you take their spot in the
realm of the living and they take your
place in death we kill someone we get
their life I don't make the rules
interesting
it's about to be the purge yeah he laid
it out pretty clear for the first time
yeah but those happened in the rules
every time yeah I know but he actually
like was pretty direct about it and now
it's coming after the rest of us no not
all of us she lives Molly made it she
didn't die when I had that Vision I got
you a cross before the bridge collapsed
because you decided that you deserved to
live more than the rest of us apparently
you deserve to live more in Candace so
unreasonable
see that it's been quite a while since
your first consultation a lot is going
on in my life
I don't want to miss anything Lasik no I
think she is the next one on the list
and then the black guys after her gonna
die during Lasik this is like the
dentist all over again damn this movie
is doing everything I wanted to do I
wanted to go get acupuncture and I want
to Lasik I'm gently going to position
your head
that's cool that's one word for it Greg
I can't move my head
comes to drop
you will feel I actually can't watch
half this movie it's just an eye drop
huh Grammy has to get shots in her eyes
oh my God every month
that's horrible yeah she's a trooper
okay all right this might be a little
boy Craig
fast forward Greg
not fast forward
oh that is gnarly oh
oh this movie knows how to toy a little
toy stuffed animal with us
they're not even doing anything gross
yet it just feels that way uh looks good
what's that mean oh what a shot that is
a disturbing ass shot oh no no the eye
on the ground the eye of the tiger did
you know what my assistant's giving me
an incomplete file I'll be right back
[__] this
oh [__] elements bro it's always
elements always the elements you're
right about it man I laughed at you on
the first movie but you're right
you know the toyed around with
electrocution a lot but we haven't
actually seen it
maybe until now I don't think that's it
no no no no no no no no nope nope nope
use your hands use your hands you have
your hands use your hands oh the cheer
ducks
wait what is what is it laser coolant
Greg do I have to duct tape your eyes
open and keep Greg I don't even like her
hands I hate her hands no no no just
move your help nope nope she can't move
her head dude
[Music]
oh no
all right
oh Olivia castle where is she she might
be in danger
there she is he not the water the water
[Music]
whoa
oh
is that what an eyeball would look like
driven over maybe so I want me to find
out I literally warned you about what I
couldn't do this would someone really
just smash through the window that
easily I think windows windows are so
tough aren't they I don't know
I want you to tell me what you think is
going on two deaths okay all right
that's a coincidence three pattern
pattern yeah baby catch up let them in
you gotta talk to his other
sophisticated black guy who knows a lot
of stuff we think we weren't supposed to
survive on that bridge and now something
is trying to write that that's all you
got but what is the entity that provides
premonitions to these people maybe Tony
Todd's really trying to save their lives
so he gives them the premonitions we all
got off the bus but the ground gave away
in Candace fell then the bus tipped over
and Isaac he never got off the bus he
went with it you getting at the order
first was Candace
and Isaac I'm Olivia who dies after
Olivia
you knew yeah I remember that but we
haven't had somebody get skipped I feel
like it's about time
it's a great setting for a cool death
contraption
what if they get in a fist fight and he
doesn't mean to but he kills Royce dies
no he kills Roy and then he gets to live
oh is he deciding right now to kill him
I think he's trying to make a choice to
kill him on accident cut my hours
corporate has operated less than 50
until this whole thing blows over my
Boogie ain't operating at 50 my dumbass
kid ain't operating let him die
[Music]
let him die
oh
that extra little Banger told you
they're gonna get in a fight yeah you
predict that right he did try to save
him though but he ended up pushing him
to his death Olivia and Isaac are dead
Who's Isaac Isaac Palmer tech support
wasn't he dead already
Dennis must be next right I'm not
[__] around here Dennis anyone could
be next
it could be you was he next on I think
so because the three of them we weren't
supposed to survive that bridge collapse
and so now it's kill or be killed
literally
what's the girlfriend's name Olivia
Molly Molly lived what if we're just
watching Molly's Vision the whole time
that'd be interesting but she's not
seeing all or I guess she could be
seeing it and not being there that would
be fascinating correct even the other
movies five is a lot of movies for a
franchise to be able to make and make
them fresh with the same premise
you kill him no no I it was just time
you know he got in the way and no you
did didn't you you you saw coming and
then you took his life it sounds like
Tom Cruise it really does yeah yes I
killed him you traded spots he should
have your death I think there's an
orders of these deaths
he looks so happy who wants to be the
first to tell me what the hell just
happened who is this yeah
who's what
we needed to save some time
is Dennis no [__]
oh that's a really gross one yeah damn
that seemed like a little bit of a
throwaway but I'm okay with it they're
like there's gonna be a solid 90.
something saved me on that bridge maybe
it doesn't want me to die oh my God he
thinks he's Invincible I like this so if
it happens tomorrow or 50 years from now
whatever as long as we're together I'll
be okay why don't you come by after my
shift and I'll make you a nice late
dinner oh what if they get on the flight
to Paris there's got to be some cool
twists right
and he just wanted passengers who dies
that would be really sick that might be
what it is Greg Greg I hope so Greg Greg
we've got like 15 minutes to find out if
that's what happens ha
unless death is now suddenly coming for
him no it's not his turn bro yeah but
these are all like the classic warning
signs for somebody else maybe you know
how they see signs for somebody another
person but there's no one else here yeah
but it doesn't always isn't always
somebody else there remember when the
other guy died in the shower and he got
that floating thing that said the guy's
name
[Music]
there's been a lot of meat things I feel
like somebody's gonna go through
I should stop filming reactions hungry
yeah I know I want meat
nope nope don't do it man
yeah I'm not smart
nope nope
I don't know I thought he already
unplugged it it was a second plug if the
offer still stands I'd like to take it
it's yours that's cool if he makes it
there you're so right he's gonna get on
the plane that is crazy if we don't know
if that's even what happened I'm
positive dude
The Internship
ooh his lips are gonna be red
why aren't they
Tony Todd oh no oh no he's gonna cause a
problem he's the next to die something
with the meat do you mind if I come in
oh
course yeah come in no I do mind so
you're gonna just kill him maybe Peter
did kill somebody always really yeah I
can believe that that's why it's this
guy's turn Peter it's good that you're
here you shouldn't be alone right now
still alive I'm next to go right it's me
and then you isn't it maybe he kills try
to kill Molly he looks just like
Christian Bale from Batman Begins take
someone else's life if I could actually
kill some stranger can't do a stranger
he's gonna try to kill Molly or maybe he
already did it that's what I said yeah I
went on a walk every couple of minutes
an opportunity would just present itself
like like clockwork that girls
hahaha
he didn't do it yet I couldn't kill
somebody that didn't deserve to die yeah
so I love The Descent of this guy and he
thinks Candace didn't deserve to die who
deserves to die he thinks Peter or Sam
for saving Molly he's pissed at Sam none
of us deserve to die then why is it you
deserve to live bye oh Molly you said it
yourself
oh [__]
stop he's gonna get fired this is just
like Titanic shots fired requesting back
a 10-26 Washington go
she didn't seem panicked enough I mean
she's not the my favorite performer I
spit when I said enough I just want you
know I know you're not a killer I don't
want to kill anybody Sam
I don't want to die yet either
oh
[Music]
don't worry Molly
ooh is he turning the deep fryers on
yeah turn everything on
dad
I actually really like the choice of
what they're doing with this guy it
smells like psychological turn they've
done with the character well we've had
almost everyone with McKinley and [__]
but this guy like we liked
yeah it's one of the main characters
yeah don't bring a butter knife to a
gunfight
oh no don't kill the cop what's going on
there well at least it took a life now
you don't need to kill Molly right you
have blocks life you're safe now she
just witnessed the murder of the federal
agent
thank you
this is smart whoa
oh
the deep fryers the surprise
oh the guy is the gun heats up is it
gonna fire yeah
and somehow he's got to get on the plane
to Paris
or we're just gonna arrive at the ending
seeing a final destination one it's one
of the two
[Music]
done Tell Candace
I love her
Peter
wowie and now he killed somebody who was
saved so now he lives yeah but then
how's he gonna live on the plane to
Paris death always comes back around not
if you take somebody's life then you
traded places
it's only if you get skipped pay
attention to the rules Greg that's right
it's gone
you killed him so does that mean I get
Block's life
yes I do but he wasn't expected to have
a long life Brock no you don't get their
life expectancy you just get to live you
trip places is this it must be because I
take the window seat are you kidding me
you're gonna make me sit in the middle
seat this is the first movie to not
mention the other incidents that has to
be a prequel
[Laughter]
that was really good Greg now I'm
impressed with myself
[Music]
that's why we didn't know the year of
that one
[Music]
it's in the Wind
I knew it would play again
he sees it there's like one thing I
don't like about this and I'll tell you
after
Vision no
no oh
so anyway they can survive us
she dies because she switched seats with
him I mean I don't think so
even if they fell out like there's no
way yeah
no damn
foreign
okay maybe death is just coming to
collect still can't believe he's gone
though
yeah he's kidding the planes just gonna
fall in here company did an autopsy for
insurance purposes turns out Roy had a
large blood vessel in his brain so big
he's about to burst they said he'd be
dead any day now so maybe you do take
their life expectancy yeah
the plane yeah
Die Young oh five four three two one oh
is there a meaning to these credits I I
don't think so I think they're just
showing us like the greatest hits
oh yeah that one's sucked
oh yeah that one was gross too
that was awful
oh yeah oh yeah
I actually kind of like them reminding
us as
oh yeah that was awful oh there were no
boobies in this movie well there was
like booby illusion
[Music]
you all just be careful now huh
interesting okay okay okay okay okay the
one thing yeah tell me don't like about
that is wow you're so negative I know
okay
this was a great finale not like we just
start off on a negative okay I wanted to
start off with a slight tinginess one
thing you don't like about that is is I
feel like on the plane that incident
where Alex was freaking I think it was
his name Alex when he was freaking out
maybe I think he thought that it was
Alex last time too right okay whatever I
know what you're talking about yeah yeah
um what's the actor's name again
when Devon saw was freaking out that was
such a thing on the plane that I'm like
everyone heard that on the plane no you
know when you're in the bat he was far
away and that's why they had that woman
ask like what was that about I think
they were trying to justify it and mask
it I think that is that's something they
would have overheard and they probably
would have been quite I think there
would have been a discussion because he
was saying the plane's gonna explode and
all this he was saying all these things
and when you say some [__] like that on
a plane everyone's going to be talking
about that I don't feel like they were
just like oh I guess that was nothing
like the everyone around because he
could still see them fighting he was in
there
he was in the proximity of seeing them
he could see them fighting here's a net
you want to pick no no no no no no no
man this is a name if he's in the eye
line to see them fighting then he should
have heard the conversation and and to
me that is that's not a nift I feel like
he should have just they should have
really established her in a completely
other cabin or something like that to
not have heard it I don't feel like they
didn't establish that they're not in a
different cabin
he looked over and he sees them before
he sees but we don't like we're seeing a
camera shot of them fighting we're not
seeing his eyeballs see or his ears hear
them
you're not wrong but you're picking at
it maybe maybe okay what did you think
of the movie
it was really good
um what do you think of the characters
this time
um I like the I like the characters I
mean okay look let's put this out of the
way it is
and every second of this movie is a
massive Improvement upon the last one
yeah yeah like I thought from the very
beginning I was like okay this is
already a significantly better movie and
I think the characters overall are
better I love what they did with the
friend Miles Fisher I love the way they
handled him because
he while we've seen shades of that
happen with other characters before we
really gotta watch this guy transform
over the course of the movie he starts
off as the like this the Plucky most
charismatic confident one of them all
and you're watching him fully descend in
a way that felt natural throughout the
movie that by the point he gets to like
killer mode I really bought it and it
didn't seemed like overly telegraphed
um but like sometimes some a choice like
that in a movie you can see coming very
early on and to me it wasn't like very
predictable but by the time it happens
it's very believable that it's happening
I think if you're gonna I'm surprised
that you say that because well I accept
it I think if you're gonna pick Nets
Jesus the fact that
he is more willing to kill Molly because
he says why do you deserve to live when
Molly ain't down [__] yeah and he's more
willing to kill her than a stranger
I I thought that was a bigger leap okay
yes which I was okay with but I'll meet
you there on the Molly thing I think a
lot of that is a an envy that he was
projecting
uh onto like just a pure jealousy he was
projecting onto his friend that his girl
gets to live and he chose to save her
and the whole thing with the premonition
like I I think there's some
justification it still is a leap yeah I
know I hear you and I agree there is
some justification I thought that he did
they did a good job him and Molly being
the the core couple in this
kind of carrying this and all the other
characters I was interested in too so
it's your understanding that the you're
taking that person's life whatever their
lifespan would have been right that's
why he ends up dying on the plane that's
why
um yeah the other guy dies in the bar at
the end and I think that's why they made
it very clear I think that's why they
they chose to show
I I remember anyone's name the black guy
um what is anybody's name in this
there's Molly and Olivia Sam and Peter
Pumpkin Eater
I don't know what the black guy's name
was either we can't look racist Rock I
don't know what David cokers gotta
remember the black guy's name look it up
but I'm not gonna edit this out we don't
remember the black guy's name I don't
remember David's name Roy no Roy was the
guy the white guy who died
who's Roy the guy who the black guy
I said I didn't save killed oh oh yeah
that was right what was the name of the
creepy guy at the at this massage parlor
that's good we don't know
no we've balanced the scales yeah
um uh but I think that's why they
established that at the very end to to
clearly State that's why
um our main guy still died I don't
remember main guys in I think that's why
they they established Sam I don't know
if that's right it looks like a Sam but
that's why yeah because yeah the second
he killed his friend I was like but the
guy was expected to die yeah so like the
life expectancy would be short what do
you think of Tony Todd of it all for not
just this movie the the entire series
franchise except for that
tennis ball racketed to you what was
your um what was your takeaway
you can't just take my question man I
just want to say you up I've been
talking more
cool um I just think he has such a
presence that he brings so much validity
to these movies that seems so weird but
like he's an icon and so to even have
him I'm not saying that the reason four
wasn't good was because he wasn't in it
but for him to be in every other movie
and four to be the one that sucks I
don't think that that's a coincidence no
like I I do think that I I wish that
there was a little more explanation for
him at some point like why he knows what
he knows or did this happen to him maybe
we see that in the sixth one or maybe
something more to how this is what he is
what he has to do with death how this
has all come to be but in general I just
like his presence
yeah I love his presence a lot here well
he said some interesting things here
because
he was saying that
he's seen this happen before and this is
in the timeline this is before the first
movie right that's what I'm saying like
how does he know did it happen to him so
yeah it's it's like damn it's been going
around this guy's life for sounds like
forever
forever I don't I feel like they should
ever really explain it though I think
keeping it in mystery and I'm sure
there's like a bunch of YouTube videos
that break it down and try to try to
explain maybe what is what his
background is but what how would you
feel if the sixth movie was Tony Todd
big prequel prequel and him
um I would know this is 2011 so that
doesn't make sense I wouldn't like it
because if he's the main character we
know he won't die
yeah you know and I think a lot hinges
on that feeling of because out of all
the movies only in part two is when when
the people survive right yeah that's
kind of crazy out of five movies right
with the barbecue yeah well clear
survived the first one
that is true but then she didn't survive
anymore that is true that is a good
point yeah I wonder how they are going
to go about this sixth one because this
is such a complete Loop
and they did a really good job of
relating some of the stories and having
them be relevant keeping it fresh
bringing us back to the Paris plane
you know what what's left what stone is
left unturned I heard someone pitch that
they should be on a cruise
dude a lot of people die on cruises
because and correct me if I'm wrong and
I'm sure I am but something about can't
be charged international waters rules
are iffy nobody's looking for them to
get thrown overboard I'm telling you I
it sounds right I think that Hassan
Minaj did a uh episode on cruises
um for Patriot Act whatever that sounds
plausible yeah the cruise thing that
would be really interesting and we're
stuck there
but then how's yeah that would be
interesting though because you would
think they would just stop the cruise
right or do we stay on the cruise
I have no idea man Titanic
what'd you think of the characters in
this one I
definitely dug them but I don't think
it's a coincidence that we're having a
hard time kind of distinguishing them
remembering some of their names this was
the first one where I felt like there
was less archetypes like the Megan Fox
looking girl was kind of similar to like
she at first I thought when she was
getting out of the car of the guy
dropping her off this was going to be
major Breakfast Club Vibes where she was
gonna be like Rebel Outcast or whatever
you know I thought we were kind of doing
that with the gymnast and all the stuff
but then they were all very similar you
know they had some turns but the the
gymnast girl the Megan Fox looking girl
Molly girl they all had similarities to
them same thing with main dude eyebrow
dude
um uh black guy and uh
there's another guy right
pervert guy now he pervert guy was
different but they were all like similar
personality types you kind of seemed
until until eyebrow dude Swift uh
switched yeah
yeah I think um
like the other ones kind of rely so much
on like such strong archetype right that
it makes them distinguishable but at the
same time I thought that this one
the friend group is the second best to
me
to um to the third one to the first one
to the first one in terms of The
Ensemble of friends like The Ensemble of
friends I really bought that they were
friends that they were actually like
when they're like because they're
similar when they're buddying at work
and drinking I'm like okay I buy them
all as friends I definitely agree with
you it's not a it's not a knock on this
movie that I thought that there were
some similarities between them and it
was less stereotypical because it was
less archetypes yeah but because when
you're asking how do I feel about the
characters I think that it is a little
harder to distinguish them from one
another yeah I wasn't a like I think
ever the actors are pretty good and I
like the cast overall you weren't that
in Denali Molly was the one I had the
hardest time believing the the problem
she seemed the most like
cw-ish I liked her but I think that they
set her up they didn't necessarily set
her up for success and I think they did
this on purpose because when we first
meet her she's breaking up with our main
character so when you see that you're
like F this girl even though we don't
know him and we don't know why and then
we find out she's actually doing it
because she loves him and she wants him
to take this job yeah so it's hard to
then kind of like switch back because
we've already deemed her to be the
villain in our eyes just shows you don't
know what's going on Behind Closed do it
you don't know about different
relationships but I didn't really think
they have Joe Jonas and Sophie Turner we
don't know what was happening I thought
I liked them but I did
true I like them but I didn't feel like
they they had the best chemistry I hear
you yeah I don't think I don't think
these movies rely on them yeah they
don't like you know I think they had
their priorities and that was not one of
them yeah and that's okay
yes I do think that this had the most
serious tone of them all like even
though it started as the comedy and
you're like yeah and I love that I think
I think out of all the movies
they the the setup here I thought was
the strongest because
it's really throwing you into their
world in this moment in time and not
horror world and then when it takes the
horror World it becomes like super
serious which I really appreciated but
because this movie because this movie
was 90 minutes but it felt longer and in
some ways that is a good in a lot of
ways that's a freaking fantastic thing
because it like pacing wise it it really
took its time and I really appreciated
that and then in some ways not most I
would say vast majority have been some
little areas it would kind of feel like
it's dragging a bit and I I'm not
exactly sure which moments here or there
were doing it but I did have that
feeling come up and I do think that the
like the humor especially wasn't
clicking with the tone they struck in
this film like the the humor did not fit
it didn't bother me but I it's not
typically a critique I have and I know
that that's something bothers other
people
um you know not everybody's always gonna
be funny and I think a lot of times
movies try to make themselves lighter so
it didn't bother me here I thought the
kills were really strong in this I was
super freaked out I was upset with you
for not fasting forward several times uh
something about the I guess like office
the spa and the eyeball and the dentist
to the previous one now we know what my
ick is so it just it freaks me out
people touching you and then you're
gonna die
they did a great job with that the one
kill in this one that was just like okay
it was the wrench thing where it's just
like all right we gotta save some time
just he's done we're gone which is fine
but it's a really good job in this one
and making the kills I want to say
realistic I don't really mean that as
much as like I could see my I felt it in
my bones I was like oh my God there's
something coming to my eye oh my you
know well I think they brought it back
to the tangibility that the first one
really had where it's not like because
like you could always sort of feel death
being like this clever guy creating this
like like the flick of a finger in a
crazy domino effect and the death stuff
didn't really do that this time around
like it was still there
um but there was such dread and tension
leading to the execution of the victim
that I thought was so well done like
there was such a deliberate pacing that
you could really feel the the suspense I
thought this movie had more dread than
the other ones specifically that emotion
and uh a doom and gloom a gloomy Vibe
over it like it felt like like it's
interesting to have like the weather be
such a specific thing because you could
feel kind of that cloudy weather sadness
sort of looming over this whole movie
completely and I I appreciated that
underlying melancholic emotion that was
sort of permeating the entire film
you're gonna hate this but I'm gonna ask
you to do it anyway what is it look
something up wrinkle rank them
um
I I really love I I like this one a lot
I would still probably make it third
okay so what are you I would go three
one five
two
yeah it makes it sound like I don't like
too but I really do like like I really
love this franchise and I just there's
one I don't like out of all five and I
would go three one
five but see there's things about this
one that I prefer over part three and
part one that that's what makes it kind
of interesting for the that's why I love
the franchise because I'm like
of other things in one that I prefer
over three there are things things in
five that I prefer over three and one
there are things in two that I prefer
over the other like every one of them
has something that I prefer over the
others and uh and even though every one
of these movies that's the same concept
characters premonition yeah oh my God
there's a pattern solve the pattern
boobs and and then uh death at the end
the there is something that they do
different per film that I that I really
that I that that's why I love this the
franchise so much
um it's wild that we're so engaged and
we binge these essentially what's your
ranking I think
three two one four five four
oh this would be the fourth out of them
this would be the bottom of the five of
the of the four yeah I'm not stoked
about that because I loved this movie
but I think that's what it was so we're
both with three at the top but you and I
had very different opinions on two yeah
um
and so I almost want to do three two
four one five but before sorry three two
five three two five one four is what I
almost wanna do okay however
it I I feel like I loved one it's just
the longest to go so that's like I feel
like when I first watched it I don't
think it's fair to put it in the fourth
position I think I should still put in
the third position which is why this one
I think should take the fourth position
I mean think about it more then I'll be
able to know if five should be in four
or five should be in three
I think the one a one two a seven an
eight and eight seven seven seven
uh I think I think for sure this one is
the best shot of them all I would give
it the the cinematography the lighting
the effects
um just overall the look of it was I
thought the best looking one of them all
yeah I feel like this one had a bigger
budget it also had better technology
because later
a lot of times it doesn't amount to it
being like the best looking Windows
that's totally true I mean yeah Wizard
of Oz so yeah there's like a there's a
visual there's there's there is uh and I
think maybe because the film also took
its time a lot more that
whoever their DP was on this was just uh
just did an excellent excellent job this
uh five and three guys I'd say the best
shot ones at them all
it's interesting the both of you and I
like three the best yeah I don't know if
that's a popular opinion yeah I don't
know either yeah you know what I really
hate that people do that I just did I
don't like when people say that their
own point is interesting
it's interesting that and then I say
something like I think I'm so
interesting you know what so you know
some of the interesting corrects what
I'm about to say is interesting usually
I think he's like that's a common thing
people say yeah but they go like you
know what's interesting this thing if I
say it a lot what I have to say who
knows what's interesting maybe you think
it is let us know uh one more shout out
to Craig Perry thanks for watching shout
out to you guys all you Rejects at home
special shout out to super sexy rejects
uh most importantly special shout out to
one particular super special section not
today no I really gotta go to the
bathroom before the last hour 20 minutes
thanks for watching appreciate it we'll
see you for the next Final Destination
whenever that comes later
thank you